he's walked the corridors of whitehall
before as australian prime minister
now tony abbott could do the same as
trade advisor for the uk
but his previous public remarks some
deemed sexist and homophobic
have forced ministers into a difficult
position as downing street considers
whether to appoint him or not
as the former prime minister of
australia obviously mr abbott's got a
huge amount of experience
i'm sure you don't support some of his
comments he's a homophobe
and he's a misogynist well uh
he's also an expert in uh trade
so one plays off against the other
really is that really what you're saying
health secretary come on
well no what i'm saying is that we need
experts in
different areas and critics warn doing
so would harm the uk's global reputation
you cannot simply say well he's good at
trades it doesn't matter he's a sexist
misogynist and climate change denier
you know i think having somebody with
those views representing the uk probably
doesn't help as
boost trade might actually hinder that
but for mr abbott strong views go hand
in hand with an ability to get things
done
inevitably if you have convictions
you'll draw criticism
but if you want to get things done you
need people with convictions
obviously i can't comment on any
position
which is not yet official but certainly
i think that it's in britain's interest
and it's
in australia's interests that this
particular free trade
deal be done as quickly as possible
international trade secretary liz trust
who recommended him for the role
also brushed off criticism today well i
think it's absolute hypocrisy to hear
this
type of argument from the labour party
and there's a sense in whitehall that mr
abbott's track record makes him well
suited for the job
in 2017 tony abbott wrote that his
success with trade negotiations came
from setting firm deadlines and making
sure as he
called them peripheral issues didn't get
in the way of striking a deal
the uk government wants trade talks tied
up quickly to kick britain off on the
right foot as it leaves the european
union
but is knocking heads together
qualification enough
i think tony abbott has shown through
what he's written and what he said
that he's very much on board with the
brexit pros project with the pure brexit
project that
the prime minister supports and i think
that for this government it's more
important to have
friends around than it is necessarily to
have the the right kind of expertise
around the uk's new board of trade will
play a crucial part in shaping britain
on the world stage after brexit
mr abbott clearly has the support of
those close to boris johnson
whether he'll be on that board is yet to
be decided
kate mccann sky news